[APPLAUSE]
JEN LANCASTER: Thank you.
Hello, I am Jen
Lancaster, and I'm
going to give you a
little bit of background
on what "The Tao of Martha"
is about and why I did it.
And then I'm going to
get into the reading.
I had the worst year ever in
2011, not for any big reason
just for like 1,000
stupid little reasons.
We moved to this house
in the suburbs in a town
called Lake Forest.
And it's called Forest
because no one's
allowed to cut down the trees
in the town-- because of Mr. T.
20 years ago.
Mr. T lived in this town and he
cut down all of the old growth
oak trees in his yard and Lake
Forest is a very snotty place.
I live on-- not the good side.
But it's a very snotty place--
think of like a New Canaan
or like Westchester.
What are the other?
Like that.
Just imagine all preppy blue
bloods clutching their pearls
while Mr. T is out front
cutting down trees in his shorts
with his necklaces and stuff
and losing their minds.
The Wall Street Journal
even covered the story
calling it "The Lake
Forest Chainsaw Massacre."
Such was everyone's-- that's
how disgruntled everyone was.
The reason I mention this is
because in 2011, because people
can't cut down their
own damn trees,
we lost power about six times
over the course of the summer.
And everybody around us had
generators except for us.
So I spent my entire summer
buying new jars of mayonnaise
when the old ones went bad.
So it was just a bad year and
by the time the year was over,
I didn't I didn't even want
to celebrate Christmas.
I just didn't want
any part of it.
I wanted 2012 to start.
So my husband said, we need
to do something in 2012 that
will make us happy,
that will get us
past this really stupid year.
And the other thing was,
I had this-- the best
dog in the world,
this pit bull who'd
been fighting cancer
for three years,
and I knew that 2012,
it was going to be over.
I knew that our luck
was going to run out.
So I wanted to
bankroll happiness,
I want to stockpile it.
And I'm a very practical person.
I'm not going to turn to Oprah
to look for things to give me
all the feels.
I want practicality.
So when I was looking for a
way to do a happiness project,
I thought, what makes me happy?
It would make me happy if my
house were clean and organized.
It would make me
happy if I could
throw a party without wishing
all my guests would leave
immediately because I've
been working for three days,
and now I just want
to sit in the bathtub
with a glass of wine
and have it be quiet.
So I turned to Martha Stewart.
Largely because every time
something would go wrong
in our house, something
household-wise,
my husband would
invoke her name.
Such as, I wonder
if Martha Stewart
has to chase all
of her asshole cats
off the Thanksgiving buffet.
The big one-- the
actual incident that
started this whole thing
was I lost a recipe
and we were having a party, and
I needed to make this recipe.
And three hours later, we found
it in our kitchen gun cabinet.
And I bet Martha
Stewart doesn't even
have a kitchen gun cabinet.
It's a teapot cabinet now.
We did not build it.
So I decided to spend a
year of my life living
by Martha Stewart's dictates,
thus "The Tao of Martha."
Now this chapter that
I'm going to read to you
is about Halloween.
And I have to give you the
background on my relationship
with Halloween.
I despised Halloween so much.
I mean it was fun
in grade school,
you know, trick-or-treating
and picking up money for UNICEF
and going in costumes and
then just being in collage
and oh, I'm a slutty
football player.
But once I graduated and I
started working a day job where
people still celebrated
Halloween, it bothered me.
Don't talk to me about your
mission statement, Batman,
I can't take you seriously
in your superhero costume.
So Halloween started
to bother me.
Especially one day when I
went to deposit my paycheck
on Halloween and the
teller was in an ape suit.
That does not build faith in
one's financial institution.
It got to the point--
and my husband
and I didn't live in great
neighborhoods in Chicago.
So we got to the
point where-- like
you don't want to open
your door for thugs.
Because they may want candy.
They may want your television.
You don't know.
I would tape garbage
bags over my windows
so it would look
like we weren't home,
because we were too broke to
actually go out to dinner.
So this is my relationship
with Halloween.
But when you spend a year
of your life embracing
the Tao of Martha, you
have to include Halloween.
That's like-- it's
not her Superbowl,
but it's definitely
a playoff game.
I mean she has like her own
Halloween spin-off magazines.
So I had to learn to
embrace the Tao of Martha,
which was celebrating.
And I started off
the Halloween season
by learning how to
put glitter on things.
I thought, OK, I'm just
going to throw some glitter
on a couple of pumpkins
and call things decorated.
Like four hours
later, I had glittered
every surface in my house.
I had glitter
Stockholm syndrome.
It was the greatest
thing to ever happen
to me in my entire life.
So I thought, I'm going
to do this Halloween up
so big you're not even
going to believe it.
So now I will get into
the actual reading.
"Because I feel a
real karmic debt
for shuttering my home for the
past decade, I'm going all out
and I'm giving away
full size candy bars.
I still remember who gave me the
big bars almost 40 years ago.
So I love the idea
of being the house
that kids recollect fondly
when they're adults."
Even though we did buy our house
because it was set way back
and it was sort of in
the woods and I thought,
we're not going to get a
lot of trick-or-treaters.
That was honest to God, a
selling point of my house.
Anyway.
"If full size candy
bars keep local kids
from playing mailbox
baseball at my house
when they become
teenagers, all the better.
Such is my Halloween
spirit that even
my husband Fletch participates.
He dons his army
surplus gear and straps
on his ridiculously
realistic Airsoft bb
guns with bonus ammo vest.
He settles in at the
dining room table with me
to wait for the hordes
of local youths hankering
for 10 CCs of Twix bars, stat.
I'm ready.
Let's rock this."
Oh, and I was also-- I was
wearing this I like 50s sock
hop costume, because here's the
thing-- when you're a plus size
girl, there is not a lot of
costumes available to you.
You can be like a
saucy pirate wench.
Or like a saucy opera singer.
So they weren't there weren't
a lot of opportunities.
And you can't wear pearls
with either one of those.
OK, so-- "4:01, one minute
into the official Lake Forest
trick-or-treating
hours, our bell rings.
Showtime.
Fletch answers the
door, while I dash
to retrieve my
tray full of booty.
With my back turned,
I hear the mailman
gasp when Fletch's body armor
slash arsenal, pretty much
scares the pants off of him."
I think our mailman drinks,
by the way, that's an aside.
"Judging from the
mailman's reaction,
I guess he doesn't usually
deliver certified letters
to the fully armed.
Clearly, he has never delivered
mail in our old neighborhood.
Fletch then
compliments the postman
on his realistic
costume and the guy
doesn't even laugh a little bit.
No candy for you, pal.
While we wait for
business, I anxiously
rearrange my enormous
silver candy platter.
Why the hell do I feel nervous?
I used to get tense
when I was trying
to dodge the
trick-or-treaters, so afraid
that they would
catch me unprepared.
But today?
I could not be more
ready for them today.
The house is super festive.
The treats are ridiculous.
And we are both in costume
with bonus positive attitudes.
Fletch is particularly compliant
because he secretly proud
that his ensemble scared
our feckless mailman.
He had me take a bunch of
pictures of him in his costume,
and then he posted
them on Facebook,
adding caption on
how he was dressed
as an Army Special forces
guy, not a Navy SEAL.
He wrote that you could
tell he was a Green
Beret because his hands
were in his pockets.
I said that this would make
no sense to 99% of the world,
particularly since he
wasn't wearing a beret,
but he promised me that
his enlightened followers
on Facebook would find
that absolutely hysterical.
Yeah, I'm going to have
to take his word on that.
A week later, we see my
friend Stacy for my birthday,
and she compliments
Fletch the authenticity
with the whole esoteric
hands-pocket things,
and he positively
beams because he
has no idea that she's
messing with him.
Anyway, I don't
understand why I'm
anxious because I've executed
an outstanding version
of the Martha Stewart
Living Halloween.
This day has Martha's stamp
of approval all over it.
I really put in
the effort to make
everything special and elegant.
Given that my last go around
at a Martha-type event
on the 4th of July turned into
a um, redneck, white trash,
he-haw ho-down-- never
order your decorations
on Amazon, just FYI.
But I raised the bar
here exponentially.
As I take in my surroundings,
I'm confident in my creation,
and I wouldn't change a thing.
And yet I'm jittery
still all the same.
My commitment to
Halloween planning
has given me a real
sense of satisfaction
and the kind of
peace of mind I've
been hoping to gain
ever since I started
this project in January.
Once I came to terms with
my initial misgivings
and threw myself
into the process,
I have had the best time.
In fact, when I was glittering
my gourds last Saturday,
I couldn't stop
saying, this is so
fun I can't believe
how much I love this."
Oh, just FYI, the
book's subtitle
"Why I'm Never, Ever Getting
All That Glitter Off the Dog"--
believe it.
"When I was
decorating yesterday,
I realized that I was
singing to myself.
Badly of course, but
that's not important.
Breaking out into song is kind
of my good mood barometer,
and I haven't done that
since we lost our dog, Maisy.
And this is for me
is so significant.
A month ago I honestly worried
that I would never feel joy
again I couldn't go through
a day without crying.
But here I am moving on
and letting happiness
in without feeling
guilty for it.
While I wait, I merchandise the
big bars in attractive rows,
and I group the
treat bags together."
They were shaped like
witches and broomsticks
and they were full of mini
candy bars-- like ten, come on.
"I decide I'm going
to let the kids decide
if they want a full
sizer or if they'd
like to pick what's behind
curtain number two in the treat
bags I put together.
Personally, I would
go for the unknown.
Could be a bag of candy,
but it's Lake Forest,
so it could be a
bag of gold bullion.
You don't know.
As I survey the bounty, I
hope I made the right choices.
From what I understand,
children need
to be hermetically sealed in
a bubble until the age of 18,
so I'm concerned that the
chocolate bars may be an issue.
My friend recently told me
that in her kid's pre-K class
there were four
peanut allergies, one
strawberry allergy,
two gluten frees
due to issues with wheat,
one corn allergy, and one
lactose intolerant child.
This is out of 14
total students.
What do parents bring
in for birthday treats?
Strippers?
What do you do?
'Is it OK that some of these
candy bars have nuts?' I ask
Fletch.
'What do you mean?
All the best chocolate
bars contain nuts,
everyone knows that.
See, you've got
your Baby Ruth's,
your Snickers, your Paydays,
plus Reese's Cups and Mars.
Also, Butterfingers count
because they use ground roast
peanuts.
Candy bars with nuts are at
the top of the sweet-based food
chain.
Fact.' He pauses thoughtfully,
and then makes a face.
'Except for Almond Joy,
those are just wrong.'
'Yeah,' I agree, not convinced.
'But what if parents give us
shit for passing out bars with
nuts in them?'
He shrugs.
'Then I suggest that they stop
encouraging their children
to take candy from strangers.'
He returns his attention to
his Facebook page and his iPad,
waiting for everyone to comment
on his hilarious pocket jokes.
I suspect he will be
waiting for a while.
Speaking of waiting, um, hello?
It's 4:15 and we've seen no one.
Not a Power Ranger has
walked past this house,
let alone come down the drive.
4:20 PM.
Nothing.
4:30 PM.
No one.
4:35 PM.
I open the front door and yell,
'Kids, I have lots of candy.
Please come ring my bell.'
Fletch comments, 'That didn't
sound menacing or creepy
at all.'
4:45 PM.
I'll just have a little
glass of wine while I wait.
4:50 PM.
Did I turn the porch lights on?
I double check.
Yeah, they're on.
5 o'clock PM.
Yo, yo, yo, where my
trick-or-treaters at?
5:05 PM.
Maybe I'll have a
splash more wine.
Possibly two splashes.
5:15 PM.
Yeah, you can top
up my glass Fletch.
It's not like I'm busy
giving anyone candy.
5:30 PM, more wine.
New bottle, more wine.
5:35 PM, spill my glass,
prompting Fletch to exclaim,
'please don't lick wine
off the furniture.'
5:40 PM.
I tweet, come and
get your damn camfy
see before I am too drunk.
5:45 PM.
It's wine o'clock
somewhere, but mostly here.
5:50 PM, I tweet, I am Linus in
the GD pumpkin patch right now.
Come get your stupid
candy, you stupid kids.
Augh, I hate you.
6:00 PM.
'Maybe all the neighbors have
been busy with soccer practice
and dinner, and they're
just now getting
to trick-or-treating,'
Fletch suggests.
6:05 PM.
Then I had better fill
up before the onslaught.
6:10 PM.
Onslaught, onslaught, anyone?
Onslaught?
6:15 PM.
How long does it take for
them to remove their cleats
and eat some chicken fingers?
6:20 PM.
Yeah, I'll have more
wine, thank you.
6:30 PM.
I'm starting to
see two Fletchers.
One of them has his
hands out of his pockets,
so he must be a Navy SEAL.
6:45 PM.
'What are we doing for
dinner?' Fletch asks.
I respond by chucking a
Milky Way at his head.
He says nothing, instead
opting to bring me more wine.
7 o'clock PM.
I open the door and shout,
'I have full size candy bars,
you little assholes.
Come and get them right now
so you can have your magical
Martha Stewart
memories as an adult.'
Behind me, Fletch
mumbles something
about needing some pizza to
sop up all my excess Halloween
cheer.
7:10 PM.
I kind of forget what
happens after this.
11:43 PM.
I wake up surrounded by
snoozing dogs, an empty pizza
box, and one very smug spouse.
Fletch tells he had to keep me
from accosting the pizza guy
when he rang the bell a
minute before the official end
of trick-or-treat
time at 8:00 PM.
Fletch sent him on his way
with an extra large tip
a handful of Snickers bars.
I have no recollection
of this but I
suspect he's telling the
truth because Green Berets are
notoriously honest.
I'm still a little groggy as
I change out of my costume
and don my pajamas while I
reflect on the whole Halloween
experience.
I did it.
I faced my enormous
fear of Halloween
and with Martha's
guidance, I got through it.
In fact, I got over it.
I don't despise
Halloween anymore.
I'm not sure I love
it, but I'm not
going to go all Jehovah's
Witness in the face of it
anymore.
I began traditions this year
that I'm going to continue.
Maybe I won't ever wear
my costume to the bank,
but I sure as hell will
decorate some gourds.
I might make my whole
house festive again.
Maybe I'll even host a
party for my friends' kids,
because damn it, someone needs
to receive some full size candy
bars.
Even if they're
not my neighbors.
In terms of personal
contentment,
I feel exponentially
better about life
at the end of October than
I did at the beginning.
Working on this project allowed
me to focus on something other
than missing my dog, and prove
to me that I can absolutely
be happy in my life again.
I was able to strengthen
bonds with my husband,
and I started having
fun again, so much
so that it was able to share it
with readers on social media.
So the Tao of Martha
tenant that I've taken away
from this experiences
is seize the opportunity
to create new memories
and traditions.
Hey Halloween, you and I,
we're no longer in a fight.
We're officially OK.
Am I going to put you
back on the buddy list?
Well, that remains to be seen.
But the one thing that
I can say for sure
is that I am glittering
the shit out of Christmas."
Thank you. [APPLAUSE]
I don't have to hide
behind my podium
when I'm not holding my papers.
I love talking to people.
So if you guys
have questions, now
would be a really
outstanding time to ask them.
AUDIENCE: I have one.
JEN LANCASTER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What did Martha
Stewart think of your book?
Or did she write
to you about it--
JEN LANCASTER: OK, here's
the deal with Martha Stewart.
And you guys already
heard this story
so you just pretend to be happy.
When I started working
on this project.
I started working
on it in January.
In April of that year, I got a
call from my film agent saying,
hey, how would you
feel about doing
a show with Martha Stewart?
I would feel real
good about that.
I don't know what
that would look like,
but I would feel
real good about that.
So we sort of went back
and forth with ideas
because we were with
the same agency.
I suspect they actually
return Martha's calls.
I'm just guessing.
So they were trying
to figure out
what they could do with
the concept of the show.
And they wanted to do a sitcom.
But I didn't know how
to write a sitcom.
I know how to write books.
So they paired me
with a screenwriter
who came up with the
concept for the show.
And the thing that is-- I don't
if it's funny or insulting,
but he based the whole
thing exactly on my life.
And took it to the networks and
they said, wow, we hate her.
We hate everything
about her, so he
had to make the main character
10 years younger, thinner,
divorced, and with a
kid to make her likable.
Because apparently when
you don't have kids,
you're not likable.
But it was still, it was
some sort of in the stages,
and it was sort of working.
And over the course
of the summer
they were able to get Martha
herself to sign onto the show.
So when it came time to go
to the actual pitch meetings,
Martha Stewart,
the screenwriter,
and Brian Grazer of
Imagine Entertainment
went to all the networks.
I was at my house picking up
dog crap in my dining room,
literally the day that they
were in the pitch meetings,
because I became
superfluous to the process.
And the show sold.
NBC and Fox both wanted to show.
The show ended up
being sold to Fox.
And this was all very
cool and very exciting.
It ultimately didn't get made--
which is a shame because Martha
was going to be in
the show, and she
was going to say the line that
I would have killed or died
to hear.
She was going to
say that glitter
is the STD of the
crafting world.
I mean to hear her say that,
that's an iconic moment.
So the show ended
up not happening,
but this whole time-- like
six months before the book
came out, we were going to be
on the Today Show together.
And I was beside myself.
The Today Show came to my house
and filmed my Cinco de Mayo
party.
And we were all set for it.
It was going to be the
greatest day of my life.
And the day before
I was supposed
to be on with her, I get
this call and they said,
oh Martha may not be there.
What do you mean Martha's
not going to be there?
Because she's on the TiVo guide.
Because I preset my
TiVo before I left.
So then I thought,
oh, I know what this.
This like on "Ellen"
where she has
the kid in the
wheelchair who couldn't
go to Disneyland with
the rest of his church
because the church's bus is
not handicapped equipped.
So Ellen gives him the
mouse ears and kids, like,
oh this is so great.
This is such a great day.
But then she pulls
back the curtains
and there's a minivan
handicapped equipped
for the kid and his church.
This is what I thought
"The Today Show" was going
to do for me,
because I love Martha
and they know that I
love Martha because I
said nothing but nice
things about her.
So I assumed that
they were just going
to tell me she wasn't
there and then they
were going to surprise me.
So the whole night
before, because I
didn't want to look
really stupid on TV,
I made like attractive
surprise play faces.
Because, you know I didn't
want that to happen.
So the next to the
next day when I'm
on TV with Savannah Guthrie,
she's interviewing me.
And I'm yeah, OK, whatever--
I'm like not even listening
to her because I'm
watching the whole time,
waiting for Martha come in
so I can be really surprised.
Yeah, she did not come in.
So you can see at the end of
the interview when it's over,
I'm just like-- you can
see me just deflate.
So yeah, Martha
was on the next day
with the chairman of
Match.com because I
suspect they wrote her a check.
They wrote her the kind of
check I cannot write her.
So I have never met her.
And now it's like my
Susan Lucci moment,
the not winning the Emmy thing.
So now it's just funny,
but now I'm kind of mad.
Is she here?
Because I'll forgive
her, I totally will.
I keep sort of
half expecting her
to show up to my event tonight.
And over the course of all
this stuff with the TV show,
I got her email address.
It is all I could
do not to subscribe
her to like the
birdwatcher's of the month
newsletter, because I'm mad.
Because this was a
lovely book and she
was so behind the TV
thing, but the book--
she told someone that she
thought it was charming.
Well that's great, could you
tell someone else, anywhere?
Like on your show or
something or in your magazine?
But no, so I'm not
that happy with her.
But I'm willing to forgive
her if you guys have
any ins with her.
Anyway, what else would
you guys like to know?
Or are you afraid that
if you answer a question,
it's going to be 10
minutes long again?
AUDIENCE: How did
you get into Martha?
I've been a fan since I was 12.
JEN LANCASTER: Really?
See, I didn't like her.
I didn't like for years.
Oh no, you should
be afraid of her,
because I think that she
could make you disappear.
I mean I really do.
But I didn't like her.
I thought she was smug.
And I thought she made people
feel bad about themselves.
It wasn't until she went to
prison and came back humbled.
I mean, she rose to the
occasion and I respect that.
I respect anybody who goes
through something hard
and comes out
stronger than ever.
Because she could have
been released from prison
and then just gone off and
lived her life as a billionaire
very quietly.
But she came back and
was like, oh, I'm sorry,
did you think I wasn't
still Martha Stewart?
Because I am.
I love that.
And in prison, she made friends.
She made ponchos.
she learned to make
the microwave dinners.
I thought that was outstanding.
And then, she made
fun of herself.
And oh my god, if you want to
make me fall in love with you,
then have some self-awareness.
And she did.
And it was when I made her
buttercream cupcake frosting
recipe the first
time I thought, oh, I
think she knows something.
And my life has been
exponentially better
for living by her dictates.
The one thing that I did over
the course of this project--
I wanted to do something
that she hadn't done.
Or I wanted to take
one of her ideas
and turn it into something
that was strictly my own.
And this was around the
time of Hurricane Sandy.
So I thought, what
I'm going to do
is learn how to
prepare for a disaster,
and over the course of the
book I accidentally became
one of those preppers with
a basement full of food.
To the point where
my prepping made
me forget about
Thanksgiving coming up,
and that's when my husband
said, you have to stop this.
Because I was asking
him questions like,
what's our water filtration
process going to look like?
Where are we going to get
sources of fresh water?
Should we have carp
to put in the pool
if the balloon goes up?
And he's like, you have to
stop this, you're scaring me.
So that was an
unfortunate side effect.
But otherwise the
book went really well.
And I gave all of the
food to a food bank
when I heard that all these
people lost their SNAP
benefits.
And that out worked better.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
JEN LANCASTER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What was your
favorite Martha mem--
like what was your favorite
thing to do in the whole book?
JEN LANCASTER: I'm trying of
what my favorite thing was.
Well, I'll tell you what my
least favorite thing was.
I thought that I would
really be a good gardener.
Because that was
always something
that sort of interested me,
and I always lived in the city
and I had container gardens.
You know, you have your pot, you
put your dirt in, it's great.
But we had this
house and I thought,
I'm going to garden this house.
Here's the thing about the
dirt that is in the ground.
It is hard.
It is damp.
It is full of bugs and full
of clay and full of roots,
and it sucks.
I was trying to plant
pansies in my front yard,
and I sat on a fire ant anthill.
And I was wearing-- it
was like 1,000 degrees.
I was wearing a bathing
suit and track pants.
And I threw my pants off
in front of the house
and cars were running
over it, and I
was running around like crying.
I'm not a fan of gardening now.
I really thought but I would do
well with that but I did not.
I loved Halloween.
Christmas was great.
This is the greatest thing
in the entire universe.
My Christmas
presents that year--
because ultimately I
still had to be me.
So I had this ribbon
custom made from a place
that Martha Stewart
recommended and on it it said,
ho, ho, ho, motherfucker.
Come on, would you not love
to get a Christmas present
wrapped up that?
Like oh, what a beautiful gift.
You're so thoughtful.
I thought that that
was outstanding.
And then this last year
I was going to-- oh,
I had something else dirty and
I forgot what I was going to do.
I didn't end up doing it,
but that was really fun.
Yes?
JEN LANCASTER: What
was more exciting,
the cost of being like
Martha or the time it took?
AUDIENCE: You know, I ended up--
because of living like Martha,
I ended up saving both.
Because my husband
and I are big people
who-- even though neither one
of us actually has a day job,
it's 6:30 and there's
no plans for dinner.
So we were ordering from
Grub Hub every single night.
But in living by
Martha, I actually
was better at planning things.
So we had food that
we made ourselves
that was better than
what we could order.
And it ended up
being less expensive.
And it actually helped
us plan our time.
And I became much better
at throwing parties and not
hating everyone
who was in my house
that I just wanted to leave.
Like every time they're
like, oh I'm having red wine,
but I'm going to
switch to a cocktail.
Wishing them dead because
they dirtied a second glass,
you know.
AUDIENCE: Did you ever have
a successful Halloween,
where any kids came and--
JEN LANCASTER: No.
AUDIENCE: Never?
JEN LANCASTER: Two years.
No kids.
AUDIENCE: Where did they go?
JEN LANCASTER: I don't know.
They don't come to
my-- I think it's
like-- I live on the
west side of Lake Forest,
but the east side
is all rich kids.
And they either have people
go get their candy for them,
or they don't care.
I mean because
when I was a kid, I
got 50 cents a
week for allowance.
You can't buy much candy.
That was like how I got
my stores up for the year.
Maybe these kids can just
buy candy themselves.
I don't know.
They were not into it.
And then this year--
2012, they didn't come.
2013, they didn't come.
This year, I'm not
even turning lights on.
I don't care.
You've had your chance.
They had their chance.
They're done.
yes?
AUDIENCE: So, what was the
last day of the year like?
And then after that,
what are the things
that you maintained in your life
even though the year of Martha
was over?
JEN LANCASTER: Well, we didn't
have a New Year's party,
because I'm not a
New Year's person.
But the last year, we ended up
having the same holiday party
that the book begins
with, except I
was able to do everything
right and actually enjoy
my friends' time.
So now a party between
Christmas and New Year's is
our big thing.
And now that I've done a few
times and I've done it well.
This year, we have
a bunch of people
that stayed at our house.
I bought us all matching
Christmas jammies.
It was the greatest thing
in the entire universe
to see everybody at my house.
It was like this twisted
Christmas morning.
Everyone in their matching
polar bear pajamas.
So now I'm really good
at throwing parties.
And I learned how to not make my
4th of July party really white
trash.
Because the first year,
it was 105 degrees.
And we have a pool,
and the pool is heated.
And I'm-- because I don't
want to spend the money to put
in a hot tub, I like to leave
the pool like 95 degrees
so it's nice when you sit in it.
But I forgot to turn it off
so the air was 105 degrees
and the water was 105 degrees.
so you jump in the water,
and there was like no relief.
It was just liquid hot.
So I mean everybody was just
terribly, terribly dehydrated.
So my husband came up with this
thing called the Dew Driver,
which is Mountain Dew and vodka.
And everyone was drinking
these enormous tumblers
of Mountain Dew and vodka,
so it was so white trash.
It was so bad.
But it was a lot of fun.
So I took what worked
from that party
and I have applied
it to other things.
I'm not cooking that much
now because the big thing now
is furniture, which is
completely esoteric.
Since I still listen to
Martha Stewart on the radio--
because like I said, I'm
a little mad at her now,
so I like catching her when
she's not doing things well.
And she had a whole
network on Sirius,
and now she just has a show.
So she lost her network and
you can just tell she's mad.
She just met every
time she's on the show,
and it clearly overlaps
with her lunchtime.
So when she's on the
show, a lot of times
you can hear her
eating her lunch.
And she's not even
try to disguise it.
She doesn't care.
She so does not care.
So this one kid called in.
It was right before the 4th
of July, this last year.
And he had really high voice,
and his name was Thomas
and she was mad
at him because she
was convinced he was a girl.
So she was just mean to him.
She was just mean
to this poor kid
who just wanted to do fun
games with this family for 4th
of July.
So she's already in a
mood, eating her lunch
angrily-- talking, yelling at
kids for having high voices.
And the next person that called
in was this college girl.
And this college girl
said, I'm looking for ways
to make my first college
apartment fun, cute and neat.
And Martha's advice-- why
don't you shop at Pottery Barn?
Bitch, that's where my
nice stuff come from.
And then she remembered,
that oh yeah, Macy's pays me.
Or go to Macy's,
that was her advice.
And that made me angry.
Because I worked for
a really long time
to be able to buy my
stuff from Pottery Barn,
and it made me mad that
she thought that-- then
it made me mad that
college kids maybe actually
could shop there.
So I thought, how would
I have answered this?
Because I like to guess
her questions sometime.
Like how would I do this?
And I had heard about this
stuff called chalk paint,
and it's like you can paint
over furniture without sanding,
without priming or anything.
So I got a can of it, and
I started painting things.
And now it's this whole actual
side business that I'm having.
And I have an art show
in Lake Forest on Friday
where I have like 40
pieces of furniture
that I've completely like
rescued from dumpsters,
and yard sales and
I'm going to sell it
at extremely inflated prices.
I feel like Martha
would approve of that.
It's such a weird way
to get into a business.
It's like, well I was mad at
someone eating their lunch
on the radio, so now I have
a new line of business.
But it worked.
So I mean, that's
really stuck with me.
Like every time I do a book,
and I try to reinvent my life,
not everything sticks.
But some stuff does.
Like a few years ago, I did
this book about culturing up.
And the one thing that really
stuck was going to the opera.
So now I go to the opera like
four or five times a year,
which is not anything I
would ever expect me to do.
So things do stick,
not everything.
Anything else?
Anybody else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you plan
on writing another book,
and it would be a
memoir or a novel?
JEN LANCASTER: I go both ways.
I do both.
I'm actually working on
two different projects.
Right now.
One is a bucket list type book
that comes out next spring.
It's called "I Regret Nothing."
And they'll just be a
lot of-- my generation,
I'm Generation X. The first
members of my generation
are starting to
turn 50 this year.
We're in our second
act of our lives.
The things we want
to do, now's the time
to do it before
we are all too old
or are hips hurt or whatever.
So I'm going through like
doing bucket list type items.
Like my husband are
going to Italy for
the first time in two weeks.
And I'm going by myself
at first because, I
want to go to a
different country
and try to speak the language.
I've been taking lessons.
So that's one of the
things we're doing.
I'm also working on a
couple of different novels.
So yeah, I always have
something in the hopper.
Because I like to buy stuff.
I started my career
with the book,
"Bitter is the New
Black" which is
about us working
during the dot com era.
So let me tell you how
angry I am being here,
because I was like 12,
14 years too early.
They had the razor
scooters then,
but they didn't have the
infrastructure to support it.
So now that this is
actually successful,
I feel like I've been gypped.
Just so you know.
So I have to talk about the
fact that your toilets are not
the cool Japanese ones.
But most of the whole
point of that book
was, we kind of lost
everything and then we
reinvented everything, and I
wrote my first book about that.
So now everything after that is
kind of a logical progression.
Did that make sense
because I kind of
forgot what the question was.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
JEN LANCASTER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Where do you get
the ideas for your novels?
Like the time travel one, and
then-- the body-swapping one.
JEN LANCASTER: My second book.
My second novel is
called, "Here I Go Again."
It's my favorite thing
I've ever written.
It's about high school
mean girls, time travel,
and the band Whitesnake.
And it is like the most
critically well-reviewed book
that I've had.
I've got like starred
reviews from everybody,
from people who have
previously written
about wanting to
kick me until I'm
dead because they're not fans.
But part of that was my husband
was planning his high school
25th reunion.
Because my husband was like
a big nerd in high school.
Again, before his time.
Because he would have been so--
people would've loved him now,
like with this nerd tendencies.
So he was planning his
25th high school reunion,
and he was doing all of
it the way he wanted it.
He was a committee of one.
So all he did was talk
about this reunion.
And it began to
infect my dreams.
So I started dreaming
about high school reunions.
And with the first
novel that I wrote,
I thought I was being so clever.
I made the characters exactly
like my husband and me,
and I put them in the
same circumstance,
moving from the
city to the suburbs.
And I thought I'm a genius.
Nobody has ever mixed
fact with fiction before.
You know what, there a reason.
It confuses people.
People don't like it.
So when I wrote
"Here I Go Again,"
I wanted to make sure that
no one picked up this book
and said, how come
you and Fletch
are calling yourselves
Mac and Mia now?
This doesn't make sense.
So I want to do something
where no one thought it was me.
So I came up with
the idea of someone
traveling-- a high
school mean girl,
going to her reunion finding
that everybody that she was
so awful to in high school is
really, really successful now,
and she's not.
And going back in time
to change herself so she
could be happy in the
future, with varying results.
This needs to be a
movie, just so you know.
If you know anyone,
you let me know.
And then the one that
I did most recently,
"Twisted Sisters," it's
about a TV psychologist
who works on like an "Oprah"
type show where they give
people full makeovers--
like mental and physical.
But the network buys it, and
she's forced to cut corners.
And there ends up being a
magical realism where she just
body swaps with them.
Just to do the event that
they can get on camera.
And her entire life is just
ruled by sibling rivalry.
Because I had this
thought that-- I
think having a sister like
having a best friend who
you hate sometimes.
And so that was that was
where the theme came from.
I'm always paying
attention though.
I'm always looking
at what's around me.
I'm always observing
because I want
to know what people are doing.
So then I can still those ideas.
Anything else?
are we good?
OK, well thank you guys so
much for coming and listening
and everything.